[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24
sara de colmenares ella no está con
nosotros fue una niña que dejó el mundo
injustamente por un sistema machista y
feminicida micro desde venezuela por la
fuerza cuando solo tenía 12 años y era
víctima de explotación sexual fue
hallada sin vida el 24 de enero con
signos de tortura y abuso un hombre fue
detenido por ser el supuesto perpetrador
pero se sospecha de una red de que la
tráfico en redes sociales su caso es el
de cientos como ella en el país miles en
todo el mundo víctimas de violencia
machista en este programa conversaremos
con la abogada que lleva el caso sobre
las violencias a las que estamos
expuestas sólo por ser mujeres y más
cuando hay características de
vulnerabilidad
vamos a revisar algunas de las cifras el
observatorio de feminicidios de colombia
reportó 622 crímenes de este tipo en el
año 2021 y este fenómeno es cada vez más
preocupante si se revisan las cifras
desde el
2017 con fuente en el mismo observatorio
además de acuerdo con el el global
estudio no homies hay de 2018 se estima
que de las 87 mil mujeres que fueron
asesinadas globalmente en el 2017
más de la mitad murieron a manos de sus
parejas o familiares lo que quiere decir
que 137 mujeres alrededor del mundo
fueron asesinadas a diario por alguien
cercano más de un tercio de ellas
fallecieron por manos de su actual o de
su ex pareja
y sin demora vamos al análisis
yamilé roncancio ella es abogada y
directora de la fundación y feminicidios
colombia su organización se dedica desde
el año 2019 a la asistencia de las
víctimas de estos crímenes con
representación judicial con educación y
también con emisión de alertas buscando
la no repetición yamilé bienvenida a
ella soy y no es nada fácil la tarea que
usted eligió cuál es la realidad que
encuentra hoy en el delito del
feminicidio
angela muchísimas gracias por la
invitación
bueno nosotras
observamos a esta realidad como una
realidad que no se modifica a pesar del
perdón de la modificación de las leyes
y eso ha generado pues que el aumento de
los feminicidios pues se vea año tras
año la realidad es que los feminicidios
no solamente se dan en un contexto de
pareja en un contexto en el que sí
entiende como un feminicidio íntimo sino
que también ocurre en casos de
feminicidio como el de sara y
colmenares
en el que se puede dar en un contexto
explotación sexual
precisamente nosotros decidimos
contactarla en ellas hoy después de
recibir la noticia de este feminicidio
de saray un caso sobre el que usted ya
ha dado detalles en otros medios en
medios locales colombianos y en los que
para nosotros pues no es necesario
ahondar en este momento queremos hablar
más del contexto que rodea este y tantos
otros casos porque sabemos que hay
algunos casos de feminicidio que tienen
muchísima visibilidad en los medios de
comunicación otros de mujeres más
vulnerables o que no involucran a
figuras públicas pues se quedan
escondidos y dejamos de percibir una
realidad que es dura pero que existe y
que hay que combatir
sara era una niña de 12 años era una
migrante venezolana era una niña abusada
además usted lo ha señalado en
declaraciones a medios a la vista de
todos porque nuestra incapacidad para
protegerla normalizamos el abuso y
además le pusimos el apellido de trabajo
sexual
bueno ese es el discurso preponderante
en colombia lamentablemente
que existe un pretendido trabajo sexual
lo cual contraviene abiertamente la
convención para la eliminación de todas
las formas de violencia contra las
mujeres cedaw por sus siglas en inglés
en la cual en el artículo sexto está
absolutamente claro que la prostitución
es una forma de violencia
lamentablemente en colombia este
discurso ha tomado fuerza tanta que hoy
por hoy se dice que aquello puede llegar
a ser empoderan te y eso tiene un
impacto directo en las niñas porque se
observa ese contexto que es un contexto
violento y de explotación como un
posible proyecto de vida que pueda
llegar a ser digno cuando eso
absolutamente
pues no está relacionado con la realidad
y eso está relacionado entre otras para
hacerlo muy breve con la cosificación
que sufren que sufrimos las mujeres
desde el momento en que nacemos y
tenemos pertenencia al sexo femenino esa
cosificación se dan niñas y adolescentes
durante toda su vida y permite y
facilita pues que dentro de un contexto
explotación sexual de prostitución pues
seamos entonces más del 88 por ciento de
víctimas mujeres adolescentes y niñas
con todas las implicaciones que trae
además de la violencia sexual que se
vive allí accesos carnales violentos
actos abusivos la misma demanda
explotación sexual llegando incluso
hasta el feminicidio pues como en el
caso de zárate
y las víctimas de violencia sexual y que
son además potenciales víctimas de
feminicidios que digamos sería lo peor
que puede suceder en esta cadena o en
este ciclo de violencia usted lo ha
dicho son mujeres y niñas que están en
la calle que son visibles para toda la
ciudadanía que son visibles para las
autoridades pero pareciera que no existe
aún a pesar de crímenes como el de sara
hay una política clara para evitar que
las niñas que las mujeres lleguen a esas
situaciones de vulnerabilidad y de
violación de los derechos humanos
yo sé que su fundación trabaja con
voluntarias y que ha llegado un punto en
el que ya no pueden asumir más casos y
no pueden asumir más defensas y más
destituciones de derechos pues porque
las manos no alcanzan como dicen su
experiencia ese proceso de restituirles
los derechos o de sacarlas de la
situación de vulnerabilidad
pero nosotros como fundación
específicamente no podemos hacer ese
trabajo decir ese trabajo únicamente le
corresponde al estado porque allí en
contextos de explotación sexual
lo que tenemos que sospechar siempre es
de la trata porque es que no hay forma
de separar la trata de personas con la
prostitución con la explotación sexual
entonces allí lo que tiene que hacer el
estado proxy una obligación legal y
convencionales búsqueda activa de las
víctimas y es el estado quien debe
brindar la protección porque claramente
hay estructuras criminales
organizadas detrás que pueden aumentar a
las mujeres sobrevivientes nosotras como
fundación lo que hacemos es en los casos
en los que lamentablemente ya hay una
muerte pues asumimos la representación
judicial con el fin de que en el sistema
judicial se entienda que lo que está
pasando y como tú lo venía diciendo
angela pues es que no puedes simplemente
quedar en una sentencia sino que tiene
que impactar una política y esa política
por más de que exista en el papel pues
no se está viendo materializada
el país entonces como lo decidas e
inicialmente ha normalizado que en todas
las ciudades tengamos lugares en los que
están a plena luz del día y ante los
ojos de todo el mundo niñas siendo
explotadas adolescentes y mujeres lo
cual pues facilita que estos casos se
repitan
y la repetición de los casos depende
directamente de lo que no haga el estado
pero también entendiendo a la sociedad
como parte del estado que sigue como lo
decías tú
normalizando la explotación en colombia'
normalizando y además también hay una
variante de completa desprotección para
estas ciudadanas aquí esta era una niña
venezolana de origen venezolano que
emigró por la fuerza colombia y pues
mire no pueden evitar preguntarse dónde
estaban los papás donde estaba la
policía donde estaban las instituciones
encargadas de velar por los derechos de
los niños que existen en colombia más
más la responsabilidad y el compromiso
que ha asumido el gobierno colombiano
siendo uno de los países que más recibe
migrantes venezolanos en la región
latinoamericana entonces pues hay aquí
un montón de circunstancias que se
juntan y que lo que hacen es dar más
vulnerabilidad a situaciones como la de
saray hay algún manejo especial o algún
fenómeno especial que usted esté viendo
en el aumento de feminicidios
por ejemplo de mujeres migrantes
pues lamentablemente han llegado a un
país en el que
tienen incluso las mismas autoridades
autoridades de renombre que ya saben en
estos casos discursos xenófobos
eso ya en sí mismo es grave
en segundo orden pues es un país en
nuestro país también es un país con el
crisis económicas con grandes cantidades
de la población empobrecida y pues
llegan en la situación de vulnerabilidad
en la que la recomendación 38 de la
cedaw deja claro que desde el primer
momento en que se inicia la migración ya
para niñas adolescentes y mujeres
empieza el riesgo de ser víctimas de
trata con fines de explotación sexual
pero también con fines de explotación
laboral y también matrimonios serviles
entre otros entonces aquí pues tenemos
un país que no ha respondido a sus
mujeres pues colombianas a las
nacionales colombianas en esta misma
situación y que además tenemos una
sociedad en la que se hacen incluso
chistes con eso entonces cuando empezó
la migración venezolana
y hacían chistes con la reducción de los
valores que se pagan en contextos de
explotación sexual y ahora en la
situación con ucrania esta mañana me
enviaban memes también en el que en los
que hacen chistes con eso sí entonces
que ahora vengan las ucranianas que van
a ser más baratas entonces siguen viendo
a las mujeres ya las niñas como cosas
que se pueden comprar y cuando a la
sociedad se le dice que se puede comprar
algo eso es un objeto que no tiene
derechos y por tanto la muerte de no hay
muerte allí simplemente la destrucción
de un objeto si no hay una visión humana
sobre las migrantes tampoco sobre las
mujeres colombianas pero sobre las
migrantes es peor porque hay una
desconexión absoluta de la sociedad con
ellas los casos no se mediatizan de la
misma manera o sencillamente no llegan y
se observan simplemente como personas
que están de paso entonces ellas sí que
tienen además pues como un dobles
contextos pues de
además porque muchas de las migrantes
son de raza negra entonces también
tenemos el problema pues propio del
racismo entonces tienen triple
discriminación y pues la opresión basada
en el sexo pues mire ya nos estamos
quedando sin tiempo pero le quiero
agradecer mucho primero por aceptar
nuestra entrevista por estar disponible
para hablar no solamente de lo que
representa la violencia y la agresividad
tan tremenda de un crimen feminicida
sino pues de lo que nos está faltando no
de cómo nos estamos quedando cortos y
dicho eso pues un agradecimiento a su
trabajo le deseamos desde ellas hoy
muchos éxitos con este activismo más que
otra cosa y que tenga un feliz día y
solamente ya para nuestros televidentes
para cerrar que no se nos queden por
fuera los feminicidas que son las
personas que estamos educando la
responsabilidad como ciudadanos es no
educar abusadores y no educar
feminicidas gracias por estar con
nosotros en ellas hoy nos vemos
próximamente en france 24
[Música]